this animation is brought to you by the
association of migraine disorders
migraine is not just a headache it's a
complex neurological disease that
impacts more than one billion people
worldwide
you can learn more about migraine at www
migraine
[Music]
to sense our world your nerves send
electrical signals
to and from your spinal cord and brain
sensors throughout our body
collect information about our
surroundings this information is sent by
signals to our brain through a series of
nerve cells
each electrical signal is carried from
one end of a nerve cell to the other
using passageways
called ion channels charged particles
called ions pass through the channels
along the nerve
which helps generate the electrical
current at the end of the nerve
the signal moves to the next via
chemicals called neurotransmitters
communication with the brain occurs via
pathways and nerve centers at the base
of the brain
called the brain stem the brain stem
helps control
sleep heart rate and breathing migraine
is
a disease where one or more parts of
this communication system
does not function properly many sections
of dna
called genes program ion channels
neurotransmitters and other structures
that support these nerve pathways
in some with migraine inherited changes
to genes
called mutations can cause the
communication system to become
hypersensitive
most mutations do not directly cause
migraine but
in combination may explain why there are
so many forms and symptoms of migraine
disease
these mutated genes affect the function
of other parts of the body
as a result people with migraines may
also have
anxiety depression
epilepsy hypothyroidism
irritable bowel syndrome pelvic floor
pain
fibromyalgia sjogren's disease and
others each attack typically has three
or four phases
the typical phases of a migraine attack
are prodrome
starting hours before a headache aura
headache
and post drone prodrome includes subtle
symptoms
such as yawning fatigue or moodiness
experienced only by some auras may be
short-term visual changes
such as flashes of light zigzags or
blind spots
auras can also include numbness
confusion
vertigo or even muscle weakness
pounding headaches may occur on only one
side of the head
often lasting 4 to 72 hours
other possible symptoms include light
and noise sensitivity
or nausea
[Music]
finally during postdrome a person feels
like they have a hangover
which lasts another day or two migraine
attacks are often brought on by specific
stimuli
or triggers such as increased stress
weather change too much or too little
sleep or certain foods
since it may be a cumulative effect of
several triggers
avoiding as many known triggers as
possible can help reduce the number of
attacks
it is important for treatment planning
to distinguish migraine on the basis of
frequency
and character of attacks less than 15
headache days per month
is episodic migraine 15 or more
headaches per month
is chronic migraine each year about 3
percent of those with episodic migraine
become chronic
this worsening of symptoms may be due to
changes in hormones
as well as cumulative effects on the
nervous system
from years of migraine attacks
while migraine is rarely deadly it is an
invisible disease that can steal years
of quality time
for more information about migraine
visit migrainedisorders.org